you are a romantic type I'm finally sad
about you because you you came to your
first anniversary of your first date
with Sophia and you made an incredible
gift for her now a lot of us just send
flowers I pick up the phone and I send
flowers you made a book for Sophia is
that right yes I wrote a book I saved
all the texts and little pictures we had
sent to each other and like the table we
sat at on our first date at the
restaurant had a picture of that at
picture the front of the restaurant I
had like we bumped into each other years
before we went out and I found pictures
of that actual night that existed and I
made this whole book about our courtship
that is I mean this says first of all
incredibly take it easy everybody
calling and sending flowers isn't easy
you got to give the credit card number
I'm in yeah so so first of all it's rare
moments that you kept all that stuff and
that you were aware of everything that
happened then you took pictures of it
and you made this book she must have
been blown away she cried yeah crying
yeah is is she as romantic as you are as
she does she do similar kinds of things
for you she's a romantic but like I'll
give you an example you know we both we
we read each other our own vows
at our wedding mhm and I actually kept
her first draft of her vows to me
because so you wrote yours out I wrote
and I bet yours were really beautiful
right they were not well actually when
we were up there I said my vows and then
she took the microphone and said mine
aren't that good yeah but I kept the
first draft of hers and it was written
on the back of a Virgin America barf bag
so she just kind of banged it out yeah
on a barf bag yeah so just in case yeah
you